let's go and take this one real quick
since uh cuz we we might lose it CU
these CH these this chat go goes by
rapidly here you go here you go yeah LOL
John never claimed to be an eyewitness
tell me where he did LOL he just put his
own words so uh and it uh two good
places you could go here Sam Gospel of
John or uh letter of John to precisely
if you're talking about whether he's an
eyewitness yeah and in fact if you want
go to John 19 and we read
25-35 John 19
25-35 you're going to see what those who
were there witnessing John recording
what he saws an eyewitness say in John
19 because I want to start to at 25
because you're going to see he was an
eyewitness to the crucifixion itself
John 1925 to35 let's go to John 19 25 to
we're going to read 35 guys pay
attention not only is John going to
claim to be an eyewitness he's going to
even testify that he was there at the
cross with Jesus's beloved mother all
right
ready therefore the soldiers did these
things but standing by the cross of
Jesus were his mother and his mother's
Sister Mary the wife of clus and Mary
Magdalene when Jesus then saw his mother
and the disciple whom he loved so
there's a disciple that Jesus loves
standing nearby he said to his
motherwoman behold behold your son then
he said to the disciple behold your
mother from that hour the disciple took
her into his own
household after this Jesus knowing that
all things had already been accomplished
to fulfill the scripture said I am
thirsty a Jar full of sour wine was
standing there so they put a sponge full
of the sour wine upon a branch of hup
and brought it up to his mouth therefore
when Jesus had received the sour wine he
said it is finished and he bowed his
head and and gave up his Spirit then the
Jews because it was a day of preparation
so that the bodies would not remain on
the cross on the Sabbath for that
Sabbath was a high day asked pilate that
their legs might be broken and that they
might be taken away so the soldiers came
and broke the legs of the first man and
of the other who was crucified with him
but coming to Jesus when they saw that
he was already dead they did not break
his legs but one of the soldiers pierced
his side with a spear and immediately
blood and water came out and he who has
seen has testified and his testimony is
true and he knows that he is telling the
truth so that you also May
believe so the very writer is saying
that this is based on the eyewitness
testimony because he was there and he's
recording as an eyewitness now one more
David if we can go to First John if you
want but one more in the same gospel
John 21 and someone even mentioned it 24
and 25 John 2124 and 25 all
right this is the disciple who is
testifying to these things and wrote
these things and we know that his
testimony is true and so there's a group
of them David it's not just him but
there are a group of other individuals
confirming the veracity of his testimony
as an eyewitness and then go on 25 and
there are also many other things which
Jesus did which if they were written in
detail I suppose that even the world
itself would not contain the books that
would be written notice I suppose and
then there is a group that's testifying
on his behalf saying we the I is the
writer and there is a group saying yes
we're telling you that what he's writing
he's doing so as an eyewitness and we're
here to confirm the veracity of his
witness and then just two more points
real quickly for salmon player salmon
player I hope you're listening by the
grace of Jesus Christ even your oldest
extent biography on the life of Muhammad
I mentioned this yesterday I'm going to
repeat it again you can get the English
translation by Alfred Gom and in the
English translation it's Pages 103 104
we cite it in our responses and articles
you can find it on our websites there we
are told by ibak that it was the Apostle
John he says the Apostle John who wrote
the Gospel of John from The Testament of
Jesus Christ based on the very gospel
that God gave Jesus for the followers of
the Gospel did you hear that I isak says
John the Apostle wrote down the very
gospel God gave to Jesus for the
followers of the
gospel and what does iak site John 15:
23 to chapter 16 verse1 so even a Muslim
Source your oldest extent biography on
the life of Muhammad agrees with the
traditional conservative hisor IAL view
that the Apostle John wrote the Gospel
of John and then the final Point final
point I want to make if you're going to
reject the Gospel of John because it's
not based on eyewitness testimony for
the life of me how then do you believe
anything Muhammad says about any of the
prophets in the Quran especially when he
quotes let's say Jesus and his followers
when he's writing 600 years after the
eyewitnesses were dead if John is to be
rejected cuz he's not an eyewitness how
much more Muhammad who wasn't even
living in the first two generation of
the eyewitnesses m and uh notice notice
the other the other problem here that as
we pointed out yesterday Sam what is the
first place where's the first place
Muslims today go we're talking everyone
zacher Nik shabir Ali Ahmed D do um uh
yusha Evans where do all of these guys
go if you say hey when the Quran says
that the gospel talks about Muhammad can
you prove that can you show where the
gospel talks about Muhammad where's the
first place they go you better believe
it they go to the Gospel of John and the
pericle passages